[Music]
george i haven't seen such an uproar and
i don't know when
dave i made the mistake of asking on
instagram what are y'all's thoughts on
this whole student loan thing and
apparently we're not the only ones with
opinions you think i've never seen
people so angry
yeah it's um it's a deal it's a real
deal so if you haven't heard president
biden announced yesterday that uh he is
for giving ten thousand dollars uh for
of student loan debt for anyone making
under 125 000 if you were getting a pell
grant at the time 20 000
um
no idea how he's going to fund it
no idea how it's going to be implemented
no i i mean the government officials are
running around like like uh ants on a
hot tin shovel i mean it's it's just
like uh because they don't know what how
the crap they're gonna do this because
it's kind of like you remember when they
announced the ppp thing oh yeah and we
didn't have the staff to execute the
stuff
and people started spending the money
before they could actually get it and
then they never got it so here's the
thing
we still don't know
i don't know maybe it's out there and
i've missed it but i said yesterday on
the show i think he has to get
congressional approval on this i don't
think you can do a 300 billion dollar
transaction without congressional
approval i don't think you can do that
with an executive order i might be wrong
i'm not a legal scholar but pretty sure
i'm right which means he's got to run
this through congress and here's what's
interesting
you won't know if this is real
by the time you vote in the midterms
brilliant political play just leave the
carrot dangling well it may not go
through
good chance it doesn't go through
exactly as it is i mean you try to get
something through congress come on even
if they're on your side right
and if it doesn't go through by midterms
and congress flips over
and it's no longer democratically run it
will never go through and so biden just
got all you people stirred up if that's
the case for nothing
if that's how it goes down
now won't that be a politically genius
move well we'll just rile up both bases
even more yeah create more political
divisiveness i told you guys four months
ago three months ago that when you know
when they moved it to december to august
31st on the extension of the no student
loan interest i told you
midterms are coming this president will
announce something in the last week of
august about student loan forgiveness
and it probably will have no teeth now i
was wrong about second part because this
has got teeth he stated exactly what
he's going to do and it is substantial i
thought it was going to be some wispy
thing like he said the other day we
forgave nine billion dollars worth and
it wasn't he didn't do anything it was a
school that went broke and they have to
forgive it it had nothing to do with one
of his programs it was regulations that
were already in place but he's walking
strutting around taking political credit
for it so uh very interesting though so
he did he you know but you know he's
it's the worst economic presidency since
jimmy carter i mean the guy everything
he touched turns to poop when it comes
to the economy i mean we got we got
inflation we got high gas pumps we got a
recession we got stock market going down
we got interest rates going up we got a
housing market slowing i don't know when
the economy smelled this bad it's been a
long time and i'm old well you know the
timing is as the young kids say sus
which means suspicious dave i'm teaching
you something here yeah that's what they
say yeah it is sus for sure is it why
wait a year that's not really it's
brilliant political move yes so what you
do you back up for your midterms where
the democrats are going to take a
bloodbath
and you throw a hail mary
and you go i'm going to help you i'm
going to give you more money
only you're not going to really know if
i am by the time you have to vote
oh it's just do you think that
positioning is
from if you're a political manipulator
the positioning is just brilliant
it's just brilliant it has nothing to do
with it being good or righteous or
principled no i'm just saying if if i
was running for president i would do the
exact same thing i mean that's just if i
had no principles i mean that's exactly
what i would do
because it's just the way he set it up
and it all and you know now he does
apparently have the executive order
ability to extend through the end of the
year no interest so that's good we can
kick so those of you that got if you do
get the ten thousand dollar forgiveness
we are unabashedly happy for you no no
sarcasm whatsoever we want to celebrate
anyone who's getting anybody who gets
help from anything that is burdening
them we love it we're happy for you it's
all good we're if someone is broke and
out of work and can't feed their kids
and they get welfare checks we're not
mad at them we want to help you do
better than that over time because
that's not a recipe for a good life but
for the short term we're not going to
shame you for taking help from the
government that is legally offered
ever yeah never have uh now we'll tell
you if we think it's stupid and we'll
tell you if it's not sustainable if it's
a bad long-term plan for your life which
usually government help falls in all of
those things but uh but but
so we're happy for you
but we're also angry simultaneously with
all of you who paid off your loans and
did the right thing and were moral and
said i signed this i have an obligation
i'm going to honor my obligation i'm a
person of integrity and now i got
screwed or i feel like i got screwed and
the reason you feel like you got screwed
because you got screwed that's why you
feel that simple
so uh some people have a right to be
angry people have a right to be happy
it's it's a mixed bag here but most
people are angry because they know how
well that's in our that's in our feed
yeah i mean we're our feed is going to
be people like that it's not you know if
you went over in some left-wing thing
some left-wing whatever wingnut thing
you'd have their feed is all that he's
saint biden or whatever that's that
because that's just you know we got a
bit of an echo chamber going here sure
but there is precedent that i'm worried
about where people go okay well why pay
off any more student loans well what if
there's more forgiveness and here's the
thing i've been saying this since the
beginning and it's in the documentary
borrowed futures i've said it years and
years and years ago i've been saying
over and over you really can't forgive
student loans while you're still making
them if the reason you're forgiving them
is they're horrible and damaging to
people and yet you continue to make them
that's intellectually dishonest
so if anybody else with common sense
other than a politician would go wait
this is hurting people first let's stop
it
and then let's try to help the people
that were hurt stop the bleeding and i
could i could get involved in that
conversation yeah but that has nothing
to do with politics that's just like the
right thing to do in common sense and
stuff if this wasn't politics that would
still be the solution is not to put a
band-aid on it so you know what are you
gonna do with bubba who takes out ten
thousand dollars in january
we're gonna be right back where we
started even if we forgave every student
loan and across america what do we back
break to where we started today yeah
four years from now because they're
still making them
so i mean
you know when you're 18 you can't buy
beer but you can go 100 000 in debt
there's just something stupid about that
y'all
but it's our american right dave
i mean
um
i don't even know how to respond to that
that's so stupid i just wanted to throw
that out there for you
it's our american right to be stupid
that's right well you do have the right
to be stupid that is the beauty of
freedom is that you you got the right to
be dumb
um to the tune of uh 300 billion my
pastor used to say the beauty of america
is you know the right to be wrong and so
uh that but i agree with that that it's
just an interesting discussion it's
interesting when you view it for the
political lens which we're not politics
people but this one's kind of sush well
i think up on it quick thank you gen z
they just you just gonna see just here
listeners youtube listeners just are all
running around in circles cheering and
throwing up confetti right now i'm just
happy i thought dave something new it's
hard to teach an old dog new tricks
careful
someone just called me a dog a young dog
new tricks
you still call me a dog dang it i can't
win with you people